in this capsule we will see the
problem the generalization into
learning parents inevitably
until now suppose it
value functions or functions
action value and she presented in son
in the form of tables, for example
if we did learning tb that
meant that somewhere but me
we had a painting where we had to
1.0 our estimate of its value for
if we had his own estimate for his
value is instituted now that's it
can cause problems
the first problem is that if
the state space is immense and such
that if they generated a chart with
all the values ​​for each of the states
that would give a huge number
it could be that we can afford
without memory
the second problem that is just as
important is that it actually becomes
impossible on this representation the
to generalize to a new state here
if he has never been visited before by
example imagine that we wish
develop an agent who plays at heart and
so in that that if the representation
of a state should contain inter alia
the formations on the cards of a
player for example if our player
4 'and a king of spades maybe that
currently other ways our agent
felt that the association value is
by 10 points now maybe that
for 4 to 6 1 1 three quarters it if a
value of 9.9 so this is estimated due to
makes that their players several parts
he observed that when he had 4 to 0 to
two peaks it gave ten points 1 then 4
at 6 1 3 because it gave a value there
estimated his share to 9.9 white what
which obviously arrives on four
years is enough rock who plays anyway
a lot of parts but now
imagine that I'm coming into a new
part I have to make a decision
for the case where I actually khatera and
body clues and that's a hand
I have never had until now
how should money be
then make an estimate from there
then associated with this amazing when
also clearly the determining fact
it's the fact that there are four to it's
really what influences the most
possible the high value associated with
to have this but then when we would like
in fact it is to be able to
generalize from observations or
I was four years old because this is the
most important factor
so I would like that if I new condition or
g4 to sign any other case
I would like so much less to have a
rough estimate of its value in
just returning a value enough
high just due to the fact that I'm 4 years old
in this case now then to do
that what we are going to do is we are going
replace the table with values
individual for each of the states by
actually a linear function that goes
try to approach but eventually my
table that I could have used if
maybe I had to love myself dead or if
was not too much state then that I
could make sure to have visited all
the states at this time so I'm going
replace my empty table with a
linear function that will take that goes
represent a state with multiple
characteristics that i will noted f2i s
escapes that one of its features
their vote to write an aspect a
property of my state and to make a
estimate of the videos is felt I
will have a set of parameters that
will multiply my characteristics
so I'm going to have a linear function
who will take a state is what will
calculate all its characteristics and
who will associate who will calculate or
estimate the value for this summer you have there
by multiplying each of
characteristics by the parameters and
a1 and a2 up to tétouan m or internet
the number of features then do
the sum therefore says otherwise
my life estimate is going to be
a linear transformation by mastered
by my state settings of my vector
from f1 to f
an example of characteristics
for poker so f for example Thursday
a movie it could be f10 one of
features to be from 1 6s
corresponds to a hand with 4 to 0 otherwise
so that the head to associate with
this function tames it is 6th cfdt
rate is your some way a score
associated with having four aces in
his hand because I'm having a liver
head to break from 10 to really be
the figure that will fit left that goes
influence the value of my state if I have
actually four to ten in the year
so learning has been transformed into
of learning we will find the
value of established parameters such as
tea life you voted close your belongings
to approximate the true function of their lives
of s then for learning ding
so how are we going to adapt our
parameters is that we're actually going
take a very similar yes approach
at the guardian descent
so we look at the rule
of tv learning we see that it's in
do my life value ds I'm going to
change by taking my current values ​​+1
early learning times a species of
two factors here a delta that tell me
it must increase or decrease my value
speed but his record could
interpret it as the deltas that
I had in the neural networks to
know the delta world that would be
basically the equivalent of less
the partial db versus a cost that
I try to optimize the flow
partial of a stroke that I try
to optimize compared to screw them is
now empty es in my approach where
mobilized by a function
linear low speed depends on my
parameters t2i so what I could
to do is actually spread this gradient
cement
this term there that I consider as
ingredient to get a gradient or
partial derivatives compared to the teil
and dense that if I do the math it's going
to be just my term that I have here
who this one here but where I just put
the rates to properly indicate if I
hate to say that
corresponds to my function estimated value
by the transformation so there is
I love this world and twice
ben the value of the feature that
multiply head
i f2i is what we see that it is very
similar in form to example
of learning in regression
logistics where I have a delta xxy and that
that's what the game has to do to
update my my settings are
noted w he in the slides on the
logistic regression so the summer rate
is a bit like the double empty
we are cured of learning in the
deposits so previous and will end
to the film but we just got
drift and partial of the output of my
calculation for my estimation of the 2nd by
compared to your tons actually
since it is a mineral function
was simply f girl so the term
which multiplies t tons we can do the
same for the quiou learning
but in this case we will rather estimate
our action function value when
it's once again a transformation
lunar characteristics but in this
here my features that I have here
it's going to be characteristics that
describe a property of my state and
a possible action so fds to that for
is equal to 1
if my hand is four years old and
that action that I consider these of
would do so in this case head to
1 it would be a kind of scor associated with
do the action at orly
if I have a hand with four years and
again I used it even
approach to der wien rough
learning in the body or
I use an approximate function
linear like this here to model my
function that in this case I'm going
interpret this term there as a drift
and partial - the partial drift of a
blow compared to the output of the
function that i'm going to multiply his
part drift and partial of my
function as compared to a hyper m
head on there is one combines with the function
so also clearly the derogatory
partial ass compared for example
you are you have a brain tf1 if hideous gdf
so that's going to be the rule of setting
day for my settings and yes I
would apply it for each of
parameters of tons for the near
parent adaptive dynamic pressure
in this case what we value is
rather my transition model
I'm going to I just mention this
quickly so it's possible
to use the near by the primature of
function to generalize new
states by modeling my distribution
conditional like that as being
the exponential one more time of a
linear function of features or
there but characteristic describe a
spirit pair
an action while I will do this game
takes the exponential because the
politics must be positive alas this
time they would be proportional to
all these terms here here so another
way to see that is to say that in
do I have a tie here here I
should have a
I will have a tie here and then here I
divide by the sum on all
possible values ​​of these spirits
maurice of the numerator and so I
would finally normalize my numerator
russia for his week in this case too
in video it basically corresponds
learning is being denied or to
every time I observe that from
the state in the state s
when I do the action did a
transition to a spirit but I can
Finals in shape
still exists there as the problem
to predict spirits from hesse and
so it's possible I'll show it
not here I like you can watch
in the book and then the references in
is to have more details but
so woven possible to define a shot
drift well ingredients for
lead my site settings and
introduced a style and there is also
a way to do the same thing so
to have an approximate function
for in the course of looking for
political plants so of parts and
controlled in fact but political
finally and for that it's a concept
which is a little bit more notions
before if you're interested invites you to
consult section 20h points 5
then an example of application of the
generalization with apprentices
function matters
so it's a very beautiful illustration
did this was demonstrated by toro in the
development of nest to pot the bagad
so that's described in more detail
in the ip if you want to have some
references among other lots that describes
in detail how did that
been doing the system in question was
baptized ligaments inclined when so
it was to model the function our
function of values ​​or actions of
value using a neural network
so rather than using a function
linear as I write them up
now
we could also do the approximation
be a function of the 2nd or a
function the ass values ​​what is it
could model it as the
out of a network of neurons since
finally take the deltas the
spread across the entire network
so if that gives then some of the
same way that a class ferline rc -
and then five reasons to make that
gives if actually a modeling of the
tank function at the time my function
of allers more powerful than a
mining function had initially
when they are interested in developing
an ia for backgammon
they started with an approach
they asked experts to provide
targets after saying explicitly for
the function of the time when the function
covered in dances only if a movie there
approached they used a
approach with colors and threads
so they asked for a state of the
party was giving an action possibly
experts to give a value according to
a relative value of associated with
carry out a coordinated action for a
eto'o is
but it turns out that it's still
really made here for an expert
to associate like that a real value
between currencies ends up more infinite for
a state a given action and the result
is that it gave a player who
was competitive account computers
the other automated systems in this
talent but not against humans
the second approach they followed
later it's learning
by a reinforcement they made a
variant of learning and and
assets or the function of values ​​and and
brings here but with a network of
neurons and they actually cause the
neural network played against him
even
so if it allowed the network to come in
to make a name but ends up part because
that he never had to play against
add and play against him even this
what I mean in fact is that
it was the same network of neurons that
finally dictate to both players
what specific actions and since the
solve we did not really
of interest has favored a player more than
the other in the end we will have you
can learn from the result of the
part of the gaming experience of the two
players at the same time and so they have
actually train the neural network with
learning the assets on 30000
part is this it gave after several
iterations and then a modification of the
system
a player who was competitive by
report actually to the top three
players in the world
it will be a very nice success in
learning parents necessarily based
on the apprentice mater of function which
based inter alia on a network of
neurons and for more details
I invite you to consult book which
gives some city references more than
details on this approach